hey everybody Alexis right here at the
Tokyo Game Show I'm here with n who just
played a bunch of Metal Gear Online well
I would say lunch but I played a couple
of matches with a bunch of strangers
exactly how many traders how many people
can play in Metal Gear Online it is an
hv8 scenario so it's the the mode I
played was kind of like a team
deathmatch mode where you had to
eliminate whittle down the other teams
number of tickets yeah I don't know what
significance I think it is but hey there
you go
so there were two ways of doing that you
need to kill them with guns or you could
crank them and Fulton them out of the
match and flattening them actually
seemed to get you more points they'd
also played into this a bounty system so
if you kill more dudes you get a bigger
bounty placed on your head and then
people feeling you means your team lose
more tickets but if you call them people
you also reduce your bounty which is bet
but it's such a weird mode because I've
been playing a lot of phantom pain right
now and the way I play phantom pain is I
sneak around and I tranq God and all
that kind of stuff I'm gonna go online
you have like 60 people running around
like insane people with continued on
signs of the ass [ __ ] Wendy walk is
like Little Neck walking things and just
like firing minions all over the place
so it's definitely like a very different
dynamic to your sandwich the middle um
right now so what would make so if
you're saying that sort of the stealth
elements maybe aren't quite there
promoted what about Metal Gear Online
makes it Metal Gear I wouldn't say
they're they are still there because
there are certain loadout that you were
able to pick which were very stealth
focused and some of the these letters
included like self camo tranq guns only
there was CQC focused loadouts that only
had like closings weapons like shotguns
and that playing as a stealth attack
code applies a lot more
everyone is always moving very fast so I
did get CQC quite a bit so when you're
on the Walker you're a very easy target
because it counts a bit closer into your
person so you can easily get pulled off
from behind and you know strangled and
killed I'm saying with anti-aircraft
guns and tarts like that but it is much
wonderful many people when they came
into this game we're playing a running
gun and so interesting so there are
human characters yes is DG there d D of
V dog is not then but every team has a
team leader so we the two teams we
played in were team collar and team
liquid and the hello team solid as can
imagine is Big Boss the immersive snake
and the head of team liquid was Ocelot
and each of those guys had their own
specific word out so snake sort of had
like a rifle which had a visible laser
sight so when he was aiming at dudes the
entire team could see where he was
pointing out you can find the enemy's
Ocelot I didn't get to see a lot of him
but you seem to have the revolvers
obviously and he could really like to do
so that makes it kind of milling that
makes it kind of Metal Gear much more
high-octane so maybe if you play Metal
Gear 510 campaign and
so it's like metal gear drink a bunch of
redbull and then got that wine yeah wait
the French people that's cool yeah so
when are we getting married
so I its ability was coming out October
for consoles that PC no real word yet so
we can look forward to that very very
soon I'm actually looking forward to
playing it because once people actually
get into it and I start doing cool self
self gonna be a lot of fun to play
because I played it'll get online I'm
gonna get like four and this is on park
it's on pod because the movement of them
it'll get stolen five it's so good
alright so if you liked Metal Gear Solid
5 you'll probably like Metal Gear Online
for all of your news from the Tokyo Game
Show 2015 at stay tuned to games.com
you